[Music]
welcome ladies I'm Jasper McDaniel beer
pilot
it's cool
no clothes this bag looks just like mine
we have to call Jasper there's something
off about him I say we do one just one
you make me drop like
where's our little Bloodhound Daisy
we're coming for you
expensive
we have to call the cops come on noon
bring the product and I'll bring your
friend if we call anyone she's dead we
need to handle this we're going together
to get a call in a minute
answer the phone
read what I wrote we have what you want
but we also have a very particular set
of skills skills that make us a
nightmare for people like you let our
friend go now but if you don't he will
find you and we will kill you
[Music]
[Applause]
this
[Music]
what next then all cats real she's crazy